now thousands of telecoms workers are
going on strike today in a dispute over
pay it's just the latest round of
industrial action as unions from sectors
across society push for deals that in
some way reflect spirally inflation well
i'm joined now by the labour mp sam
terry who this week lost his job as
shadow transport minister after joining
a picket line uh son terry thanks very
much indeed for talking to us so you
were sacked by the labour leader sakir
stama
he said for making up policy on the hoof
in uh
interviews that hadn't been agreed with
the labour leadership so you must have
been expecting to be sacked
no it wasn't to be a totally honesty i
didn't have an intention of giving tv
interviews i went there and has asked my
opinion and at the end of the day i
thought it was about time that we were
really clear about whose side we're on
i'm on the side of ordinary british
workers on the side of people going on
strike whether it's here today at bt
tower in central london where bt have
got not only their chief exec with 32
pay increases for himself
they're actual lowest paid staff having
to use food banks in the bt call centers
i think it's really clear whether it be
rail workers or be
is that the labour party is on their
side i didn't make up policy all i said
is that surely it should be right that
we offer workers in this country to
match inflation at least because
otherwise all they're getting offered is
a real terms pay cut and that's simply
not good enough after 10 years of
austerity and on top of that spiraling
inflation over the past few years
well sir kirsten will say that that is
making up policy on the hoof and he says
that collective responsibility is
absolutely vital in the running of
parties
this isn't about me or kiyostama this is
about the labour party demonstrating
it's on the side of ordinary british
workers in this country people are a
snapping point you know when it's a
hundred pounds to put car petrol fuel in
your tank when it's costing thousands of
pounds to some people's medium-sized
homes to even heat them or pay the
energy bills and when people's wages in
real terms are shrinking every single
day we need to be crystal clear we're on
your side we're on a side of ordinary
british people and you know none of
these workers whether they be bt postal
workers whether it be train drivers
whether they be low low-paid ticket
office staff from tssa uni who went on
strike the other day as well they've
made a really difficult decision to lose
a day's pay you know the labour party is
the party of trade unions trade unions
are literally part of the labour party
you know and so it's really clear it's
really clear to me that we need to say
we're on your side we're on the side of
ordinary people that are suffering in
this country and that we've got a clear
plan we've got a plan to rebuild our
economy we've got a plan to invest in
the technologies of the future the
ludicrousness of what the tory
leadership candidates are saying at the
moment you know you've got rishi sunak
someone's so out of touch he doesn't
even know how to fill up his car with
petrol and liz trust a woman to
committing that within the first 30 days
of being in downing street she'd wage
war on trade unions trying to dismantle
200 years of workplace freedoms this is
the future of tory britain we
desperately need a labour government you
know some people said okay it's not the
job of a government in waiting to be on
the picket lines but i'll tell you this
if it had been a labor government in
power we wouldn't need to be on picket
lines because those disputes wouldn't be
happening because there would have been
decent payoffs on the table yeah but
what about that point i mean government
ministers don't stand on picket lines do
they
government ministers don't know because
they should be around the around the
negotiating table you know where's grant
shaps he holds the purse strings network
rail he holds the purse strings to the
train operating companies all 14 of them
that are on strike where is he probably
on holiday cause i tell you what he's
doing absolutely nothing to resolve
those disputes because actually his
former prime minister boris johnson
wanted those disputes to happen to
distract from the absolutely atrocious
way he's running this country to
distract from his corruption just
distracted his dodgy links with former
kgb officers this is what the reality of
what is going on is all about and so
labour mps from the labour party the
party of the trade union movement
standing on picket lines is clearly the
right thing to do doesn't mean that
every labour mp needs to rush out onto
every single picket line but it's about
making crystal clear we are on the side
of ordinary british workers not the
establishment okay you say it's not
about loads of of labour mps rushing out
onto picket lines but but how many will
do you think and do you think that more
labour mps could be sacked for the same
reason as you
uh look i mean i hope that they're not
but i am absolutely certain that other
shadow ministers i'm now a former shadow
minister will be on picket lines with
the communications workers union i guess
we'll see how the day pans out i think
it's a fundamental mistake to ban labour
mps from being on picket lines it
shouldn't happen never happened it's
caused a complete car crash of a week
and we should have been talking about
what we're going to do to raise wages
for the british people
you're down there with dave ward from
the communication workers union i spoke
to him a little bit earlier on and and
he said he's talking to other unions
about coordinated action what's your
understanding of what that means are we
talking about a general strike here
the tuc will have a major role in i
suppose coordinating action across the
country i don't believe a general strike
is on the cards but i do believe that
trade unions need to work together to
fight back against this government they
are the people showing true leadership
at this moment they are the people
standing up for british workers they
represent over seven million people in
this country and by the way trade unions
have been growing through the past few
years growing at a phenomenal rate some
trading is putting on tens if not
hundreds of thousands of members this is
a movement that's been rejuvenated it's
been rejuvenated because people are
turning to those that will stand up for
them and protect them not just defend
their freedoms in the workplace but
bargain for better rights for better pay
and to stop tax on terms and conditions
you know we have a generation of young
people now who are not only being told
the best you can get is a zero hours
contract you'll never be able to afford
to buy a house and actually you know
your rights at work are about to be
destroyed by an incoming tory prime
minister that's not good enough people
in britain are not going to stand for
that and people will push back and i
believe that they're going to be many
different ways that that happens
including coordinated action across the
trade union movement
okay well sam terry we appreciate your
time this morning thanks very much
indeed